foreign
put him in the Midfield played in the
Champions League against him when we was
actually successful in 2012 which
obviously the second leg was a crazy
game but played against him then
um and yeah just phenomenal I don't
think he even needs a description on how
he plays it he just doesn't look at the
name and that's it there's numbers the
way that the the amount of goals he
scored and everything he's just
frightening just
himself in Ronaldo I think for me just
playing a different planet so yeah I'll
say him how did you think you got on
against him
I'd like to say we did all right because
it was uh I think the first leg was one
Nila we managed to keep him quiet
somehow and then again the second leg
there was so much drama involved in that
it was just our year but
um now we did we did okay glad I'd have
to play against him every week